hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to west of loathing now
you may be thinking that everything is
hunky-dory and exactly the same as it
was and you'd be partially correct
except that I'm a snake oiler now oh
yeah i got the shootie snakes and i got
a snake whip and I've got deploy snake
and I've got the greatest ability ever
called shootin Annie it's all pretty
good but I'm in the exact same place
that I was before in addition to a few
new places that I want to go to before I
actually continue number one I have to
go see the crazy old professor the
professor's house because I got to turn
in my elven e co ll vom bow Elva new bow
l vom but something like that elven knee
bow LV knee LV knee bow helmet elbow I
know great let me just hmm yep okay this
will do the trick
let me just get this running and then
you'll be able to grab a key stone from
it it'll take another five scrap for
each one you need are you familiar with
the lost Dutch oven mine Grimm place but
that's where I found the chassis for the
fabricator wedged behind an unusual pile
of rocks seems like a good place to
start hunting all right I'm on it
oh yeah I got a key stone so this is
this is actually referring to another
location that I actually discovered and
I didn't want to go to it yet because it
sounded hilarious
it's The Lost Dutch oven mind and if
it's if it's a place of only fart jokes
then you know you know that I'm
interested in it but as a as a snake
oiler number one I got a snake whip what
pow and Gary's disa stuff as Gary's
always been Gary's much better as he was
now but also I'm real good with the
shooting and don't worry I went through
every single spittoon that I'd did see
before so don't worry about a van Oh No
such a smell that Gary to smelling it's
really something yeah oof Gary - waiting
out here and breathing through mouth
good call buddy with me I'll brave the
dinger whoa those are some stinky
fissures I can't get any closer now
without some stench resistance at least
now see I I've waded through so many
spittoons
I've flushed so many toilets
I gotta have some sweet-smelling flowers
to be able to conquer this horrible mind
the stench it's barely tolerable mmm so
funny do a day later
ah Ludum get miners pants in a gas mask
well I guess that'd probably help gas
masks on I've already got stench
resistance so I guess I'm okay
alright miners must have eaten down here
got clove drops and cat's eye candy
that's good it's another spittoon yes I
don't know what kind of tobacco these
miners are chewing but it must be extra
corrosive because the brass spittoon is
he whole eaten through the bottom and
dark stains underneath the withers bit
leaked out although oddly it doesn't
seem to be leaking now and it's
half-full
I guess the miners plugged the hole with
something inspect it
it's a spittoon it's disgusting you can
practically see the stink lines coming
on up a bit
come on let's not do this inspect the
spittoon ah geez fine okay you crouch
down and take a careful look at the
filthy spittoon the inside is blackened
with years worth of stains the dead
broth the death broth inside is a
rainbow sheen like a parking lot
oil spill and occasionally a little
bubble pops on the surface you can
actually feel a slight warmth radiating
off of it from whatever dire chemical
reaction is taking place in there you
realize you're holding your breath not
deliberately but from the human body's
natural instinct for self-preservation
my option is in imagine someone made a
big pot of chili con carne and left it
under the porch three rats call into the
pot eat half the chili and then die a
week later a family of cockroaches it
takes up residence among the writhing
maggots the cockroach to smoke thick
black cigars which they light with Tufts
of burning human hair that's what it
smells like
search it bad boy fortunately for you
the rainbow-colored film on the surface
of the liquid coats your hand as you
plunge into the toxic stew keeping it
from being immediately too soft up to
the bones this
Mel intensifies in your stomach prepares
to hose the keep searching your fingers
said something at the bottom of the
spittoon better pull it out fast while
you something oh you pull the world's
most disgusting pair of pants out of the
spittoon and jump back as the whole of
the spittoons bottom now unplugged
begins to leak steaming filth relations
you are now the proud owner of the worst
object I've ever been paid to think
about narrowly defeating a leather
bondage harness made from the skin of a
oh I gotta find the leather bondage
earnest I have to find that now that's
so hilarious / eh I guess oh geez that
is so funny oh my god is the best toilet
I have a can of oil wait I have a can of
oil huh oh geez oh that's a little
better didn't know it oh I have a kid I
can use that on the gate to not kill
those people I can do that because now I
actually have that but I'm gonna use
that and I didn't kill him this time
around you lubricate the elevator
liberally oh oh yeah I do get that clown
bondage harness now have a good old time
how would he get
nups canoodling in there what do we got
down at the bottom of this place you
emerge from the elevator into a deeper
shaft by the lady or lantern you see
exposed meet vanes on nearly every
surface huh my dream it's unusual that
there would be this much readily
available meet left one working mine
what were they digging for if not this
curious all right okay meet it up a good
time all right
just feeling the music this guy's
totally out of it he's gibbering and
drooling it doesn't seem to even see you
leave induce gibbering outside talking
to him hey buddy you okay
do the BOP Rob Bibble Berto Gordo glub
uh-huh
you wave your hand in front of his face
but he doesn't react at all hmm all
right it's an exposed meat vein good
hello shovels dulled the uselessness a
broken pickaxe was one of the miners
digging with his helmet he's what were
they digging so rapidly before well it
looks like the miner died trying to dig
deeper with their hands common is
flattered leading down into a deep dark
pit all right okay ooh this looks bad
finger bones are all splintered the
hairs on the back of your neck stands up
this guy seems to have nod off his own
hands before dying your heart is
pounding Jam is pretty but it smells
terrible I got an flu vyas emerald wait
I got to check out my my pants I have
these Moxie pants I'm gonna put them up
I've also got these overly tan boots
that are just to die for
oh that's good stuff I don't know what
Goodspeed does oh there it is both sides
have equal speeds whatever this year
whatever
all right this guy worked his fingers to
the bone diggin and then worked his
bones to the marrow you have to get out
of this pit right now not yet I don't
these scratches are just painted on in
wood you have to spit right now the
gouge marks are dark with blood you have
to get out of this pit right now no I
don't get any of the rocks the voices in
your head begin screaming too loudly to
ignore you have to get it out of this
pit right now fine fine whatever Oh fine
whatever rolling away I go like a coward
why am I getting out of this pit what's
going on and we dude what's the dealio
what do I gotta get out of this pit
right now what's going on here wait
there's some going on here and I ain't
too sure about it the Dutch oven mine
will spill its secrets for me whatever
wait let me check out the effluvia
styman if this Jam is half as valuable
as it is pungent you're in the money you
should probably wash your hands before
you spend it all right okay bye men so
is there some reason so why did it why
did the professor send me down here
that's the weird thing right why did the
professor send me down here let me go
back to the professor's house just to
see what's going on over there because
Oh trading yes please wander in Sally
can I get stuff for me and some needles
I've got three shovels I only need one
so there we go oh the other thing about
being a snake oil I've got a briefcase
full of snakes if you look inside I can
squeeze some venom or some medicine now
I don't know I don't know how to upgrade
my snake briefcase
you know snake Falls or snake springs is
like an unlimited supply of snake so you
just go there and you fill up your
briefcase as much as you want but yeah
that's whatever who's fighting Who am I
fighting snakes god damn it I'm shooting
an e up BAM boom bang oh I didn't get
all of them whatever
that just shoots randomly in random
locations randomly in random locations
you know how random things are I'm so
random coffee cactus
oh also I've got safecracking finally
which is nice you know anything about
ley lines screw ah ley line diagram you
say okay
check out the necromancer journal
alright well that didn't do anything for
me
well then why did you send me why'd you
send me to that god damn mine alright
I'll come back to that I got other stuff
to do too but first I'm gonna go to old
grandad because that's where the quest
the main quest is sending me and then I
got all these other places that I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go to madness
small-minded soon I like the sound of it
even though it's probably terrible and
horrifying
alright hey dude how's it going hey
what's up man you want to you want to
get a bar of soap
thanks man let me up there alright hey
dude how's it going
alright I'll be right back Hey Oh what
tank with the tap what I don't have
enough moxie oh I'm three off well is
there something I could eat that would
give me some moxie I know there would be
I've already put something on my hat so
I can't do that it's got to be something
here that'll give me some Moxie muscle
black and beans that's by one whew
that's good potted meat sounds good it's
all by 5:00 I'll eat that pie up with
the can eat the meat tastes way better
than you expected to meet it out hey
that's pretty good I'll be darned I'll
be dinged and armed all right woo that's
some good Moxie oh yeah this looks like
this stiff all right I'm gonna drink
this Blanc decent wine pretty classy
nice and stuff potion
alright muscle by eleven but you
shouldn't drink it oh you probably
shouldn't drink cow's blood I'm gonna
skip on that one skip on that old bad
boy sarsaparilla sarsaparilla Leah sour
Wawa oh okay alright then I'm gonna
drink me some you you were never sure
how to spell this and you still are
I'm gonna drink me some sharper Ilia
you drink the saw substance saspa
Oh funny funny stuff funny stuff alright
I got enough moxie
find a tap alright spirits AB syrup tap
whatever tap it tap that alright it's
all tapped out okay I'm out of goo don't
some goo there you go there you go
needing more proper anymore alright well
there you go whatever it's fine
Jesus you greedy bastard alright hi
hello hi can i nope
okay can i yep bringing me goblin elixir
what's that a potion of extra delicious
is being so good okay I'll go get that
bad fine geez whatever
oh whoa what's this this table is
covered with flasks beakers bottles and
tubes and burners and all the other
equipment that makes up a super
elaborate alchemy table including a
whole bunch of different colored liquids
and powders and such make a goblin
elixir that's easy for use look for some
instructions I just try mixing things
yeah pick up a beater and look at the
ingredient green powder is probably good
how about some clear juice that sounds
good
it turns brown pink syrup turns indigo
and starts to fizz even harder spit in
it
mixture turns mob it starts to fizz like
crazy you managed to pick the concoction
out the window and duck under the cable
just in time it explodes with the tooth
rattling bang alright fine
you find a crap scrap of paper in a
drawer that looks like structures for an
elixir but it's all in goblin science
jargon you don't understand it let's go
red lumps
mob slime green ooze shake it turns
violent starts bubbling like crazy after
a second though it settles down alright
I'll keep it sure I've got something hey
you want something got something
here's your elixir probably table moves
away from the ladder and takes a little
sips from the flask savoring the flavor
is it good yeah perfect alright that's
that's not natural all right
okay holy crap if it isn't the most
disturbing thing you've ever seen I
don't know what didn't want to know what
it is presumably a couple of goblins
popping it in here and the spores got
all mixed together they seem reasonably
chilla bad though hey guys there's jelly
beans can i - having them
oh what a fruit walks no no not taking
our fruit rocks these being ours not for
you taking geez Louise what do you plan
to do dealing with them horror talk to
him not like looking like you're eating
them a jar is still full what eating
rocks not for eating fruit rocks just
for looking at just for looking at them
not fitting through floor hole can't
leaving room fruit rocks only
entertainment being in grief that's sad
okay how about I teach you something
else entertaining something better than
fruit rocks looking at okay sounded good
i agreeing i not for certain but what
being better than fruit rocks oh by the
way instead of intimidating I got
Hornswoggle so when I want to convince
someone of something to do something or
other for that I want them to do
I gotta give them the old Hornswoggle
him you know what I mean
hooker you pull out a spare deck of
cards and pick a couple handfuls of
cactus spines off the floor to use in
poker chips and give the goblins a quick
poker playing tutorial plus they have
themselves rearranged so they can can't
see each other's cards they take it to
it pretty quickly
alright then can I have it nice alright
cool
All Right see you guys that was totally
worth my time and buy my time I mean
completely replaying the game to become
moxie specialist
oh look grandad okay we already got that
so we got to go back to jellybeans man
Roy Bean also I got to go the force of
darkness what i'ma reschedule it with my
Hornswoggle be back here tomorrow okay
see you buddy
see ya buddy pal how you doing hello you
want another one
okay god I'm wonderful alright looks
like they're all here to god must didn't
need any it's a long and weird story
well never mind man you've done a swell
job kid I've only got one more charge
jelly beans missing it was stole by a
gang of damn hippies what'd they take
him heck if I know what hippies thinking
all I know is that they took off headed
south and a little bit
West go to shroom cave I do want to go
to shroom cave I really want to go to
shroom cave oh nice I've got a shroom
picking thing is there gonna be any good
around here Wow
okay there's a lot of shrooms and hey
what's that one that one's a spicy
shroom can I get any of these what did I
buy those shroom pluckers for anyway oh
ah mushroom map I don't know what that
is but I got shroom Grove for Gary
that's nice gift Gary ah delicious this
good it's a mushroom wrap labeled room
locations and shows a weird convoluted
trail leading to a big X you recognize
the X's this very cave the source of the
trail looks like it's right near that
weird Ford full of dirty weirdos okay
alright then
oh hello this cultist is totally zonked
out cult this is muttering and twitching
in his sleep mushroom crumbs litter the
floor around him loot his belongings
nailed boom skeleton bone human ashes
burn scroll alright well not that
there's what I want burn scroll examine
it Scrolls in bad shape and you can't
really make out anything new but you're
convinced this must be another clue as
to whereabouts of the necromancer stick
the scroll in your journal alrighty then
cool ley lines cryptic note about Hell
Cour energy oh I gotta find that again
that's the one thing that I didn't
refine but I'm pretty sure these guys
are all from the fort of darkness if I'm
not mistaken the hippies are from the
fort of darkness look at these damn
hippies with their damn hippies single
hi hi can you talk to me Gary ah soldier
hearing except yeah the sitar music
isn't very mirrored militaristic is it
come on let's have a look let's go in
here why do they have all these canons
have flowers stuck in the barrels hey
what's going on here
oh hi well then sorry I interrupted I a
muffler
teeth teeth clavicle favoured teeth Wow
okay alright
CNA jellybeans teeth jaw bone teeth I
see would you like some bones you hand
her an armload of bones and she starts
mechanically picking through them
selecting some and discarding others
based on criteria you can't discern
eventually haven't chosen the best to
from the path she secures them together
with a wire and screws and hands you
something that basically looks like a
sword great deal spooky damage how about
some skull chips oh great she stops
muttering her eyes seem to focus a
little she takes him glue out of her
toolbox and president chips into a ring
have more random encounters with
skeletons great that's what I wanted I
don't have any gold teeth so I'm just
gonna leave you to that hi I'm um Fleur
salutations mum Fleur they call me the
talking dude because of my extensive
knowledge of the principles of
philosophy and the arguments and
conundrums surrounding its various
aspects of interpretations I bet that's
not why they call you that can I
interest you in a discussion of the
particulars of curtsy and philosophy
month slur
no bcn jellybeans
well first we must take care to define
our terms what does it mean to see
jellybeans what if it was icy as
jellybeans are different than what you
see
cut the grab before I cut it for you
with him no I have not but I do know
that Irene the newest scent dare I say
most delightful of our little clan it's
particularly fond of them you might ask
her can I interest you in a discussion
sure but if you bore me the city begins
anew immediately to now la la la la but
from an epidemiological standpoint
bladder the fascinating determinism
there are your eyes your posture alone
is enough to keep him talking
that's interesting oh good
aha whoa fascinating Oh My yes oh it
actually seems like some of this is
rubbing off on you
well [ __ ] I got some mystic allottee
interesting oh yes my my sir okay
goodbye all right fine
well that was weird here I thought this
was gonna be a cultist camp but
apparently net oh man I wish I had loco
weed that'd be great
I don't have any binoculars for that
hello hi are these for sale pretty cool
boots he made huh no I mean I'd like to
sell them to put their mind you didn't
make him it's funny I everyone assumes
app no these are all made by elves got
their eyes are really really disturbing
yeah man like little elf guy so hard to
see to like kinda stand on the corner
yeah you know but I was just kinda
standing here and just kind of and I'm
like oh hey got another pair of boots in
my hands kissy elves made them more
boots huh I've made a pair of boots
myself and oh like yours here's
something these yells keep making them
though I don't know why weird you know
CNN jellybeans jellybeans weird no I
haven't seen anything like that mass and
Mel's maybe all right you should open up
a boot store a store to sell your boots
in didn't have mine move it right right
the elves but the elves can't be making
them just for fun right um I think
they're making them so you can sell them
ah yeah that makes sense
dirt water you could open up a really
nice shop there all right cool hi new
phase my name is um one sec Irene great
everyone here just calls me mushrooms so
I forget sometimes how the Irene I'm
muffler what's your story
oh not much to tell as hit times gonna
first go a few months back by stop here
and never got around to continuing you
know we're like a big happy family here
and everyone's so nice and appreciate
about how I know how I was almost about
mushrooms mushrooms uh-huh they're good
for all kinds of things if you know
which ones to pick if you want I can
tell you some of my favorites okay any
jelly beans oh yeah I had some jelly
beans recently don't remember huh oh
they were in my lounge where's your
lounge I don't remember it's only there
part of the time anyway yeah I don't
know alright I'll buy a mushroom what
the hell is that opens your third eye
halfway increasing your mystic allottee
by 23 for the rest of the day goddamn I
wish I was a bean slinger now no I'm not
gonna replay the game as a bean slinger
although that'd be pretty damn cool need
thanks alright gonna mosey on down this
way see what else is in the rest of this
camp hello hi I'm Todd nice to meet you
I've been researching mushrooms okay
like how they totally get you racked
hahaha yeah I'm kidding they have
interesting properties that could be a
boon to medicine in solution to
psychological disorders that's pretty
interesting the side effect they also
get you absolutes it's just a happy
side-effect yeah if you have any
liccardi is death rip assists in fact I
do fully opens your third eye go easy on
this stuff and there's a real kick
thanks sure okay
All Right see ya jellybeans the only
thing about a lounge huh what are you
doing it's making some dumb noises to
entertain myself me too man me too
that's pretty much what I do every day
alright do you know where Irene's lounge
is yeah I do
don't don't tell the talkin dude if you
don't mind but it's in that cave where
we get all mushrooms I gotta be
[Music]
okay I got it
okay all right gonna turn off the music
this Accord must be from a foreign
country where music is way weirder all
right can I exercise with you you do not
have the proper attire before muscle
come skin before skin comes clothing you
look around and sure enough everybody
else is wearing the same striped pants
and weird fuzzy headband don't I have a
fuzzy headband do I don't die yeah I do
I actually do as far as striped pants
goes will I need striped pants which I
don't have so I'll get that later All
Right see you guys
ooh load it whoo nice artillery saver
holy [ __ ]
safecracking Oh army as you side wow
that's actually damn good that's damn
good yeah but is it any better no it's
not better it's not better it's good but
it any better
whoo military summary plot 420 great
yeah hilarious cannon loading for idiots
all right what is that
read it this book is so rudimentary
that's insulting to your intelligence
even though you don't know almost
nothing about loading cannons okay our
sound good thank you for that all right
so I need to go back to that cave and
open my third I don't know what that's
gonna do for him
scam him out of some meat hotter gotta
be hotter hot hot gotta cook cook it
right through needs to be hot hot hotter
okay all right scam him out of some meat
having trouble with your cook stuff not
hot enough I see I've got this little
bag of spices a couple pinches is
Inferno all right okay good i hog
swoggle them hog swallow they will do
them real good all right here we go
let's open up my third eye blammo I got
bacharach collect aureus the world turns
inside out as your mind replaces it okay
the difference doesn't seem all that
significant but that's fine
I'm just gonna check see if there's
anything else others have a weird
mystical open door in the middle of the
goddamn place all right I'll go in the
weird mystical door in the middle of the
goddamn pretty nice laughs all right
guys uh jellybeans lime lime jellybeans
your grant grandkids are gonna love this
kind of music you're there well then I
found the lounge and my eyes open as
[ __ ] bro Roy I got I got your beans dude
I went on a journey to get these well
I'll be that word I didn't figure on CNN
he FM jelly beans again and here you've
brought back all three jars I ain't got
much to reward you with other than a
handshake mom flirt but maybe I'll be
able to pay you back somehow in the
future
don't sweat it Roy I was happy to help
I'm a good guy
I'm a real good guy so anyway that's all
the time I got for this episode thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know in the comments how I'm doing
and you'll see more shooty shooty bang
bang in the next episode right soon so
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]